I have a death wish.
Now before you just boo me off the stage
for saying such a thing in a pandemic,
I'll explain with a little back story,
starting with my second grade gym class.
This was the longest,
most humiliating hour of the week.
My PE teacher, Mr. Jensen,
was a former drill sergeant,
and I always felt like the weakest kid.
On my report card,
he checked the boxes corresponding
to what must have been important
for kids' physical
development in the '70s.
Oh, except the one
on leadership qualities,
he left that one unchecked.
Then he added a note.
He said, "Andrea
has difficulty kicking balls."
(Laughter)
My dad, who was always the one to see
people's gifts instead of their limits,
wrote a letter back to Mr. Jensen.
He said, "Andrea may have
difficulty kicking balls,
but you should see her stand
on her head and do cartwheels."
(Laughter)
As a kid, I was usually
the smallest on the playground,
never athletic,
picked last for, you guessed it, kickball.
I took solace in my dad's sincere support.
But now, as a business owner,
I can see that ball kicking
can really come in handy
(Laughter)
Anyway, in that one simple sentence
to a short-sighted gym teacher
"but you should see her,"
my dad showed me that focusing
on strengths more than weaknesses
feels really good.
That there are other ways
to look at the world
and that it's important
to recognize each other's gifts.
So with all that great karma
my dad had built up
around appreciation with me,
it only seems right that some praise
would ultimately come his way.
Long into his fruitful
and active retirement,
he was featured in a hometown
newspaper story.
The article described the many ways
he contributed to our small
Midwestern town.
And he sent a copy of that piece
to my siblings and me
with a short handwritten note.
He was always really modest,
so he just said,
"Well, it's better than having
a eulogy read over a casket."
My dad died seven years
ago at the age of 96,
and he was surrounded by family
and friends and two hospice workers.
He left this world not 20 feet
from where he’d come into it.
He was born and he died
in the same house.
I like to think he died
as well as he'd lived.
On his own terms.
I had the honor of giving the eulogy,
and ultimately he'd chosen
cremation over that "casket."
As I looked over at my dad's ashes,
I had to smile because, you know,
our dad really loved beer.
So instead of putting
his ashes in a blasé urn,
we put them in a big, shiny beer growler.
(Laughter)
So my remarks over the growler
were a sincere tribute
to a superb human being.
Not unusual as far as eulogies go,
except for one thing.
He'd already heard it.
Those many years earlier,
after I'd received his note
about how having nice things
said about you while you're alive
beats the alternative,
I wrote my dad a letter.
And the theme of the letter
reflected a common thread
that I had noticed in his long life.
The theme of building.
Our dad had helped to build
so many things.
Gun emplacements in World War II;
a new industrial park;
a vibrant hobby as a self-taught
and later acclaimed woodcarver;
confidence in others;
a many-decades-long marriage;
a family, a home.
And he had the chance to read it all
long before he died.
So that had me asking,
why are eulogies only for dead people?
Why do we wait so long
to recognize each other's gifts?
Why are the truest compliments
and the sincerest sentiments
said about people we love
when they can't hear and savor
and relish them?
And how do we honor all those around us
who are very much alive?
So what if we turn regret on its head
and take all that love
and conscientiousness
that we habitually
express after people die
and do it while they're still here?
Because doing that eases the pain
of death and regret
for both the dying and the living.
So I set out on an intentional quest
to bear witness to people who are dying.
As a hospice volunteer,
I'm learning that those who are dying,
they want to know that they're loved.
That they've loved well.
They feel regret for all sorts of things.
For things they didn't do
and words they didn't say.
Deep down, they want to know
that their lives have mattered.
They feel really mortal.
Because they are.
As am I.
As are you.
So when we learn a loved one may be dying,
we face a pivotal choice.
We can choose to say nothing
and hope that our words
will sufficiently honor the person
who's no longer here with us.
Or we can step up and express
our love and appreciation
while they're still here.
And we can honor all those around us
who are very much alive.
I call this intentional honoring
of others “Gracenotes”.
And whether they’re written or spoken,
they're this means of freely
and openly acknowledging
someone's presence and gifts.
I know in my bones that these sentiments
lessen the pain of grief
and increase its grace.
Like a musical grace note,
they're that extra embellishment
that makes something
beautiful even better.
With Gracenotes, we let our family,
our friends, our kids,
even our colleagues know
not just that they matter
but how they matter.
And these notes also help us
to overcome the illusion,
the illusion that there'll always
be more time to let others know
how they're impacting the world.
So what do you think keeps us
from "gracing" each other this way?
Lack of time?
Fear of feeling awkward?
Unresolved anger?
Maybe a lack of forgiveness.
With that in mind, I'll tell you
a bit about my friend Sandy.
For much of her life, she had this
complicated relationship with her mom.
She was holding on
to decades of resentment.
Some of it was tied up
in her mom's alcoholism.
But now her mom was dying of cancer.
And as heart-wrenching as it was to admit,
she said sometimes she wanted her to die.
Sandy and I happened to go for a walk
not long after my dad passed,
and I said I felt this sense of freedom
and a lack of regret,
and I thought it had to be
because I gave him that note
before he died.
So Sandy decided to write her mom a note,
and she included
an honoring set of memories
about what she did love about her mom.
She called me later, she said,
"You know what?
It was like magic.
I started liking my mom.
I forgave her.
I felt compassion for her.
My heart got softer."
Here's the thing.
When we're writing a Gracenote,
you're not trying to get published
in a poetry anthology.
You don't have to sound like Shakespeare.
My guess is you're probably not trying
to get a job at Hallmark.
Just want to sound like you.
You just need to be willing to try.
You're aiming for truth,
authenticity, love.
What I've learned over and over
is that the pain of regret
is always greater than the challenge
of writing a Gracenote.
A moment of grace can be that simple
and that profound.
It's an experience
that forever touches the dying
and those who are left behind.
So what now?
You might be sitting there
thinking what you'd say
or how to get started.
Business groups and long-term
care groups that I speak to
use what I like to call
the Mad Libs approach.
Maybe you played Mad Libs
in middle school.
Maybe you still play Mad Libs.
It’s that fun,
fill-in-the-blank word game.
So with a little bit of Mad Libs style,
we get this easy-to-use
Gracenotes road map.
"You are the only person I know who ..."
"I always laugh when I think about ..."
"You will leave a legacy around ..."
Bottom line, you can't do this wrong.
It's impossible.
And if writing’s not your thing,
what if you made a video?
A drawing?
Maybe you're really good
at PowerPoint decks.
Could you write a grace sentence?
The medium doesn't matter.
What matters is the doing.
What I've learned
in this journey of my own
and in talking to others
about their losses,
is that Gracenotes create
the sense of completeness,
contentedness and calm.
I vividly recall the last night
my dad was alive.
By then he was unconscious,
and everyone else had gone to bed.
I sat with him
with my hand softly on his.
And on this unrepeatable night,
I didn't have to worry
about trying to find the words
to tell him all that he'd meant to me
and only hope that he could
hear what I said.
Instead, I could be present to his dying.
I could affirm that if this
was his time to move on,
that was OK.
I could love him with presence
and with touch,
knowing full well that my Gracenote
those many years earlier
had been a sincere and thorough
rendering of his life well lived.
Ever since, I've felt very little regret.
And I know it's because I shared
my full heart with him
before it was too late.
So I hope, I deeply hope,
that you don't know anyone
who's actively dying.
But given the times we're in,
that may well not be the case.
No matter what,
I encourage you to just look around.
People everywhere
are dying to be seen and heard,
to know how they matter.
They're dying to get your Gracenote.
So that is my death wish.
That you see how your note,
no matter what form it takes,
is like an oasis in a desert of people
who are thirsty to know
they're making a difference.
Like my dad said,
it's better than having
a eulogy read over a casket.
Thank you.
(Applause)